michael i understand from stalking you
online a little bit
yes yes that a british film director
discovered you while you were still in
med school
uh i was in dental school at the time um
discovered that's a very funny word
isn't it uh
we met i i was in uh at my favorite
restaurant in new york called lucky
strike
it was actually under the apartment that
i ended up living at in manhattan
uh down on grand street um i was having
brunch with my uh girlfriend at the time
a bunch of exes ago um and yeah
and uh he's like oh are you an actor i'm
like no i'm actually the student
um uh trying to uh start a career in
dentistry
and he was like i have a i'm a director
and um i've got a part
in my film that i think you'd be right
for and
as soon as i heard that i'm like listen
man like i'm from new york like i
i hear crap all the time it's like
whatever you know so i didn't really
think anything of it i looked him up
he was actually legit film director and
working
you know for like 20 years to be did big
feature films
so i uh i called him and i i ended up
working with him personally for like a
month or two months
rehearsing for this role i didn't get
the role but
during that two-month period when i was
working with him and i was like
i i like this i really enjoy acting and
i was like i'm gonna
i'm gonna try this out so i talked to my
parents about moving to new york
and it just i didn't look back i i
stopped going to school and uh
i started booking stuff and i yeah
it worked out what was that conversation
like because i i've heard others like
from like
comedian brian regan and things like
that he was in his last year in college
and he was going to be an accountant or
somebody like that
and they had to give that conversation
mom dad i have something to tell you
my parents have always been supportive
of me no matter what right
but the one thing was education you get
your degree no matter what and i had my
my bachelor's degree i went to hamilton
college and got my degree in biology and
that was all great
but they are both professionals my
father's a doctor my mother's a nurse so
you know you're going to be a
professional because we are
professionals and this is what we want
for you we want you to be secure
and we want you to make a lot of money
that's all they said to me but
yeah they just they worry right parents
worry they want you to be stable
and have what they didn't have you know
uh
but i told them you know i just want to
try this out like
i don't i just i'm young i i have a
liking to this and i think
that i can do it and i like it and i
want to try it
and i'm going to move to new york now
and they were very reluctant at first
and it wasn't until they started seeing
me on television in commercials or
you know tv shows or whatever and
they were like okay so you're not
homeless
because you know they worry they worried
you know in their mind an actor was
someone who would go to auditions and
just fail and
they thought i was gonna end up like in
a gutter somewhere probably but
um you know they were always a smart boy
and i wasn't an idiot
you know i could hustle like you know i
waited tables and i was able to make my
rent every month
and uh the rule was this i said here's
the deal
the day i ask you for money or the day i
ask you for your help
where i'm really struggling i can't do
any more on my own is the day i quit and
i go back to school
and i've never asked them for anything
so i haven't had to ask them for
anything yet so
it's uh yeah and hopefully i won't have
to